filling spider-man's boots isn't exactly
going to be an easy task but luckily
Marvel's got plenty of iconic heroes
waiting for their shots at the big
screen whether little luck any of these
characters might just be the answer to
how the MCU could replace spider-man
Kamala Kahn also known as Miss Marvel
has been in beginning herself all across
the Marvel Universe ever since she first
appeared in 2013's Captain Marvel issue
17 a Pakistani America Muslim girl with
incredibly versatile body warping powers
MS Marvel has since proven to be one of
Marvel Comics most popular teenage
heroes and Kamala has already made a big
name for herself outside of the comics
she's a playable character in both the
mobile contest of Champions game and one
of the most frequently used avatars and
Lego Marvel superheroes too she's
currently the star of her own solo title
magnificent Miss Marvel and the leader
of the team in champions
Marvel has also recently started a new
volume of Marvel team-up with MS marvel
as a lead considering the circumstances
it seems particularly fitting that the
first story arc of Marvel team-up
includes Kamala and Peter Parker having
to deal with a Freaky Friday style body
switch and now that Marvel has announced
that Kamala is on her way to the MCU
with her own series on Disney Plus there
could be no better time for her to step
up and take Peter Parker's place as a
high-school-aged hearts and soul of the
franchise moon nights doesn't exactly
exude the youthful optimism of Peter
Parker in fact in most of his
appearances he comes off as totally mad
the vigilantes real name depends on
which of his multiple personalities is
dominant at the time he could be
mercenary mark Spectre both he playboy
Steven Krantz or taxi driver Jake
luckily and while his level of violence
doesn't quite reach the level of
Marvel's more hardcore vigilantes such
as The Punisher he certainly isn't as
forgiving as spider-man either but Moon
Knight and spider-man do find common
ground in their home New York City and
like Spidey moon lights isn't usually
the kind of hero who blasts up into the
Stars to fight aliens instead of
midnight sticks to the streets although
admittedly Avengers can have a more
supernatural flavor than Spidey's I the
moon's Knight of vengeance
must carry out your luminous will are
you seriously talking to the moon as in
the cow jumped over still the two
characters do have a history when Marvel
Comics published the 2018 infinity Wars
line wide events which included the
creation of a universe in which many
Marvel heroes were fused together
moonlight was joined to spider-man to
create a rack Knight more recently
there's been a rumor
lying around that Marvel is looking to
cast Andrew Garfield to play moonlight
and that recently announced Disney Plus
series what a trip right MCU fans have
been speculating about Nova's first MTU
appearance ever since the release of
2014's guardians of the galaxy more
recently the name has sprung up after
Joe Russo joked about the heroes
secretly appearing in the final battle
of Avengers endgame this cosmic hero is
a member of the Nova Corps which in the
comics originates on Xandar the planet
the Guardians saved from Ronan in their
first film darienne's what a bunch of
losers big hurry to get from stumped
it's stupid to nothing at all in the
comics the Nova Corps is kind of an
intergalactic police force somewhat
similar to DC's Green Lantern Corps
there are a couple of viable candidates
who could take on the mantle of Nova in
the MCU
for example there's marvel's earliest
over Richard Rider or the younger Sam
Alexander who took the name in the 2013
Nova series while Alexander is younger
both heroes share a strong Peter Parker
in space vibe they're both very similar
to Parker in their youth the heavy
responsibilities a shoulder and the fact
they're often forced to push themselves
beyond their natural limits in
spider-man far from home there's a lot
of talk about what the pizza Parker can
grow to be the new Iron Man but in the
comics Tony Stark already has a
successor and she's pretty awesome
herself riri williams also known as iron
hearts first appeared in 2016 invincible
Iron Man issue 7 and circumstances led
her to fill the void Tony Stark left
when he fell into a coma during Civil
War to certified a genius at the young
gage Miri uses her genius to build her
own Iron Man type suit after her best
friend and stepfather
I killed by drive-by shooters but
Lionhearts didn't disappear when Tony
Stark returned she's a member of the
champions and has her own solo title in
which she has managed to step far beyond
the iron man's shadow like Parker RiRi
Williams the youthful genius whose
tragic past pushes her to be the most
she can be in April 2019 every mermaid
the rounds at Bruce banners cousin
she-hulk will be getting a team of mini
series in the Disney Plus streaming
service a rumor that was confirmed when
Disney announced that she Hulk Series at
d23 in August on the surface she Hulk
and spider-man turns off too much in
common
spider-man is a street-level hero who
jumps around and sticks to walls while
she-hulk is a powerhouse proof to the
knock down walls Peter Parker is a high
school student while Jennifer Walters is
an icon
lawyer but one thing parkrun walters
have in common is that they're both
downright hilarious as well as they are
both characters often wrestle with how
they can juggle their normal lives with
their super lives as far as the MCU is
concerns they could also cover a similar
story ground both living in the shadow
of two older more seasoned heroes check
out one of our newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]